[Musique]
je crois que vous pouvez commencer à
travailler sérieusement travaillé
sérieusement crac et voilà un canard que
nous allons d'abord on va les marquer
ici comme ceux ci un peu les pas
toujours le fantassin signale déjà à
julien pas encore fait mal là oui je
leur tour et puis je m'en vais le
désosser très rapidement parce que
rapidement parce qu'il faut que nous
pensions au temps de cuisson keane
environ 20 minutes vous disposez
maintenant nous disposons de 23 minutes
antho donc assez de temps pour le cuir
revient sur vous donne des mines en
commission eh bien je pense que je vais
me mettre moins de deux minutes de 34
pour cent trente secondes pour le sortir
du four suppose qu'il va aller au four
il va aller au four alors voyez vous je
le désordre comme ceci toujours le côté
chirurgicale cher trois syriens louis je
vais bien que cela se passe bien
c'est vrai que l'isf passait bien et
vous vous êtes césar sur les bords de la
seine sentais pas dans mes frais non
mais dites moi me dit que vous aimez les
canards vous pouvez canada
sûrement c'est une bête sympathie non
non non et d'autres sûrement je souffre
à l'envoyer vous maintenant je laisse
ici une assez grande quantité de comment
dirais-je savez quand on vous de
fondations secteur c'est pas simple
et puis je sais pas ici et ceci pour le
moment je vous le donne alors là je vais
rabat complètement les eaux complète
comme ceci voyez-vous 4 il a géré a
battu j'ai la chair du canard qui est
ici et ici
la caf la carcasse et j'ai un peu de
pâques ici la pâte n'est pas absolument
nécessaire mais c'est mieux parce que
vous allez voir qu'elle plus alors c'est
de la pâte tout ce qu'il ya de plus
ordinaire de la pâte brisée genre pas
brisé je ferme simplement ici comme ceux
ci le creux qu'il y a qui s'est formée
dans la carcasse à cet endroit là où
allez vous me donnez ce sila
dans plate ceci au nom de ces mots
s'avère sympathique que on peut le voir
ça ce que j'aimerais c'est ce que je
tiens la main qui parlent en leur
balançant des goûters si tout à l'heure
dans les mois je vous l'offre et voir où
je mets ce système comme ceci ici
à l'intérieur on va revoir ça mais pour
le moment voyez je veux aller vite alors
je viens qui n'allait pas laisser manger
des xes jeux rabat oui où je remets la
carcasse à sa place je remets le canard
lui même il redonne sa forme je rabat la
peau ici comme ceci je le retour à léo
et voilà comme si j avais pas si j'avais
un accident un jour avec vous pour
constituer les morceaux que j'ai serré
en tout cas alors un petit bout de fil
ici pour attacher les potes c'est ce
petit grain que vous vouliez vous télé
dites nous ce que vous en pensez
et bien c'est du poireau vers 4 et du
poivre vert et poseront donc par les
salaires voilà raymond m'a laissé manger
un grain de poivre vert si j'arrive à
respirer d'ici la fin de l'émission
vous êtes méchant je te donne pas les
noms
en réalité c'est un peu taquin lyon
alors conseillé aux téléspectateurs de
ne pas faire ce que je viens de faire
hausse et ils peuvent le faire sans
grand danger oui explique qu'ils nous
ont alors attendu je voudrais mettre ça
ici j'ai eu une plaque je mets le canard
dans la plaque je mets quelques carreaux
auto j'ai ici en niant que je vais
couper en trois ou quatre morceaux
sharks chacun pour moitié voulez vous me
donnez lui les quêtes à côté de vos
quatre et
voilà du cercle voilà je sol je mets de
l'huile sur l'occasion et je m'en vais
mettre ce cas là au fond je vais le
mettre au four à un four pré rif et
voilà et bien maintenant nous avons tout
le temps n'en faudrait pas que l'on
parlait de tout ce que vous voulez voilà
c'est ça c'est ça qui vous intéressent à
petit on aurait dit devient bonne à nous
intéresser aux familles c'est groseille
on va s'occuper de concombres je veux
marquer voilà du beurre c'est vous qui
m'avez dit de m'intéresser à ça c'est
votre heure c'est exact a three c'est
exact alors disons alors des convoyeurs
ont le court puis si avec une cuillère
parisienne
c'est à dire en le prenant fait hisser à
faire une zone de pêche c'est ça
exactement on en fait de petits morceaux
comme ceci avec l'exigence arrière de la
grande saison
les cons comme il y en a tout l'été
alors quand il est très frais comme
c'est le cas de celui que nous avons ici
il est inutile de le blanchir sans quoi
on peut le mettre à l'eau froide et le
retirer quand l'eau bout
c'est ce qu'on appelle blanchir certains
légumes alors voyez vous nous allons le
mettre comme ceux ci directement à cuire
dans le père nous allons le sale et très
légèrement voilà qui est fait et on va
continuer à en faire un tout petit peu
plus à ces divers cdu-verts du beurre
toussaint et alors dès qu'il aura pris
un tout petit peu de couleurs je
baisserais le feu dire le gaz le feu
tout beau tout simplement et nous allons
laisser mijoter doucement le concours
chaud et assez peu connu et en vérité
c'est très bon je vais merveilleux brûlé
mais c'est beaucoup plus digeste
d'ailleurs cuit oui on fait de
merveilleux place on commente on fait
des potagers très très bon et potage aux
commandes et par un froid en ajoutant
très peu de choses peur on peut faire
des potages en mettant un oignon coupé
faune urbaine
du concombre est mince et on le laisse
cuire doucement on le passe on y ajoute
un peu de crème de lait et puis on
laisse refroidir et on le sert froid
avec des beaucoup de deux fines des
rousses avait dedans c'est un truc
indexer la bombe écouter y en aura c'est
on va laisser ça comme ceci moi je dise
j'ai savez si vous avez ça lui ferait du
sel impossible heures et celle à
l'envoyer je vais laisser mijoter quand
ceux ci en ayant soin en attendant tant
de mal occupé à régler maintenant
catherine c'est le moment où il faut que
nous parlions d'une façon extrêmement
sérieuse de ce qu'est le poivre vert
ajoutant la perte
alors oui mais j'étais pressé gt gt de
bousculer je voulais que ça canarde
crise ces points vont alors se voir vers
frigo voilà et que bien su bien compris
alors vous savez que c'est au sujet
d'une controverse qui a eu lieu il ya
quelques mois j'avais dit que le poivre
gris le poivre blanc était plus parfumé
que le poivre noir et alors j'ai
immédiatement reçu de gens très
compétents la lettre suivante à quelque
chose près sinon c'est le pro bowl en
quelque part film et c'est vrai
d'ailleurs je m'étais mal exprimé je
voulais dire par là que c'était celui
qui avait le plus de puissance sous le
plus petit volume le fait de porter en
vérité c'est pareil également pour le
croire vers le poivre le poivre et le
poivre vert et le poivre blanc étant
exactement la même chose à des à des
états différents et à des taux
différents
celui-ci temps poivre qui n'est pas mûr
et que l'on conserve celui-là il
il est tout frais ils arrivent ils
arrivent d'afrique il est arrivé il ya
deux jours jamais dans quelques jours il
faudrait le mettre dans le vinaigre pour
le conserver ce concert est pas alors le
poivre gris spa le poivre gris et en
poivre qui n'a pas été épluchés qui n'a
pas été demandée et le poivre blanc
n'est pas autre chose que du poivre gris
mondes donc en l'occurrence voyez vous
je suis en train de préparer ici du
poivre vert qui va me servir à faire la
sauce car il faut tout de même penser
que le canard que nous préparons pas
bien qu'il soit très fortement poivre et
à l'intérieur puisque nous avons mis du
poivre vert en assez grande quantité
il va falloir quand même faire une sauce
qui correspond à peu près à ce que nous
voulons c'est à dire à cette
particularité qui est le poil
karkwa regrets excusez moi vraiment mais
est ce que j'aurai qui craignent le
poivre et qui craignent vraiment enfin
là la force du poireau qualité de soin
il faut qu'émergent d'autres choix les
amateurs quelque chose alors voici une
personne n'est pas dans lequel vous
allez voir à l'envié de vous aurez
deviné voilà je vais mettre des binaires
voyez-vous à peu près inverse à bordeaux
gens reconnaît d'ailleurs que ça arrive
d'afrique mais des personnes qui n'ont
pas de relations en afrique peuvent
quand même en avoir dans le commercial
connais pas ben oui je pense que c'est
une ça vient tout de même de chez nous
enfin deux des territoires d'outre-mer
par conséquent je pense que c'était
intéressant d'en parler je pense qu'il
ya des gens qui doivent avoir des
relations ou des enfants ou des parents
en afrique qui peuvent leur a envoyé
tellement on peut la faire avec du
poivre
valor'aisne choisir la purée le mans en
l'occurrence du poivre gris n'est ce pas
a pas de point relais du pauvre qui n'a
pas été décortiqué de façon à bénéficier
le maximum de du parfum de poids alors
voyez où je vais faire réduire ici si
vous voulez avoir un indice de me donner
il ya quelque part là bas du sucre du
sucre en poudre
alors je vais mettre ici du sucre en
poudre dans cette personne rios ici
c'est en train de mourir et je vais
faire prendre ce sont ces dîners de fête
comme ça sans rien et tous ceux et
celles que ça rien à l'eau allez voir ça
va aller très vite derrière des achats
soit 20 chatons
j'en ai mis pour 4 personnes 4
alors si vous voyez vous gâter je vais
vous dire ce que c'est ce sont des
abattis de canard qui ont cuit dans du
vin blanc et un peu de sauce tomate
c'est de les habiller enfantine qui ça
pouvait savourer ça devrait d'être ses
sympathisants
mais comme il a fallu tout de même que
je n'ai pas inscrire cette
et donc vous préparer avant j'ai coupé
c'est un motif cannage les ennemis dans
une casserole
j'ai ajouter 2 cuillères de tomate
concentrée jamais été un peu de vin
blanc un peu d'eau du sel et du poids et
je laisser cuire et voilà ce que ça
donne et ce petit faux va me servir
rythmes variés vous que vous avez et
appréhension je ne fais pas attention
car oui il me faut du caramel mais il
faut pas qu'ils soient noirs parce que
c'est quand j'ai été assez l'alsacien
alors voyez-vous là il va être tout de
suite prêt voulez-vous avoir l'envié de
préparer le vinaigre à ma portée bien
que je vais pouvoir mettre l'autre non
ça va aller je n'ai pas de petit encas
que ce soit très réduit mais non vous ne
raterez total est la même il a dans
votre jeu vous le rappellera met enfin
en l'occurrence il ya deux cuillères ou
3 2 tomates concassées comme du vin
blanc de l'eau du sel un peu de poires
et les abattis romeo ici voilà le
carreau m j'ai obtenu voyez-vous du
caramel très fluide très blond qui est
fait uniquement avec du sucre que j'ai
laissé fondre et bien immédiatement dans
ce caramel je vais mettre le poivre vert
qui est en train de réduire avec
vinaigre savoir faire un peu de bruit
mais ce n'est pas grave je garde cette
casserole
car je vais en avoir besoin bon alors
ici qu'est ce que racontent des concours
les concombres vendre est bien sorti
compte d'un tout petit peu vite
voilà on va baisser le feu afin que ça
n'aille pas trop mais c'est pas si vous
sentez l'odeur extraordinaire remix
ordinaire du poireau vert sur l'odeur
qu'ils ressemblent pas d'ailleurs à
l'odeur du bois habituelle c'est ce qui
n'a absolument pas sans effets de
parfums de fleurs de jeu dire que je
venais dans la en plus oui / non
absolument pas quelle hauteur se trouve
océanie des poivriers sont des petits
jardins d'ailleurs et pas brillé en
france mais le poivre qu'il fournit
n'est jamais n'ai jamais été toujours
très parfumée à l'odeur comme ça mais ça
ne donne aucun goût alors voyez vous
j'ajoute dans cette
ça s'appelle une gastrique dans cette et
gastriques j'ajoute la sauce que je
viens de faire le coup après le sucre
qui ont donné réduit en présence de
vinaigre et voilà mais qui normalement
devrait être réparée avec les abattis du
canard qui se trouve actuellement dans
exactement qui vit d'ailleurs
logiquement ont été préparées avec ses
abattis je garde et ils s'en servent
qu'à soi car je vais passer l'une dans
l'autre on est fort nous d'être clean
oui oui tout sera cuit réellement
réellement bon eh bien je vais retourner
le canard au four car il doit aller
[Musique]
voilà entrés le championnat thaïlandais
contente que les écuries las alors il
m'a très très bien un peu vite mais ça
c'est obligé et bien ici
nous allons pouvoir passer cette source
elle a été faite tout à fait dans les
règles la seule chose qu'il faut bien
préciser ce qu'il est nécessaire de
laisser cuire le fond pendant au moins
une heure en tout cas quoique le revenu
minimum trois câbles bon eh bien je vais
passer quelques jours au chinois car à
paris à partir du moment où la réduction
de vinaigre avec le poivre d'une part
quand on a ajouté le caramel qu'on a
fait fondre et que l'on a fini dans le
mélange la sauce aussitôt qu'elle à
bouillir
c'est là qu'elle a pu bruit
énergiquement et les prête alors je peux
donc la passé mais elle n'est pas tout à
fait finie vous allez voir nous allons
encore avoir à intervenir mais
intervenir très très peu voyez la voici
la voici je vais naturellement baissé
aussi nous changer avec une désinvolture
caméraman va vous mais il a ici je
baisse la gt1 complètement la rejetons
aussi et je m'occupe un petit peu de
regarder comment cuisiner encore mais
plusieurs vêtements bien je peux même
les recouvrir je veux pendant quelques
minutes
et bien ici voyez vos cartes et
maintenant il reste une deux petits
travers c'est une petite maison mais en
l'occurrence elle n'est pas très
nécessaire
ce n'est pas très cher mais elle
pourrait l'être alors je vais indiquer
comment il faut faire si c'est
nécessaire
prenez pas le cas je leur dis tout de
suite que la la sauce à l'épaisseur
voulu là c'était autre chose d'ailleurs
oui je voudrais que vous me donniez une
louche qui doit être interné au camp des
loges je vais la montrer avec ceci vous
donner une autre assiette rio voilà je
vais la montrer sur une assiette comme
ici nous voilà la sauce
oui oui hélas l'épaisseur l'épaisseur
convenable
c'est une sauce elles n'ont pas être
trop épaisse et en l'occurrence elle est
bien mais s'il n'avait passé
alors si elle n'avait pas cette
épaisseur ou pendriez un peu de recul
un petit fils de pommes de terre très
peu derrière comme ceux-ci rio une
pincée de dire aux gars d'une actrice
était un peu trop d'ailleurs ce pour
quoi j'avais enlevé une grosse partie je
prends un petit peu d'alcool blanc
c'est-à-dire en l'occurence voyez-vous
ce du kirsch
je mélange comme ceux ci lui qui a sauvé
j'ai bien dit qu'il regarde jamais le
doigt c'est absolument nécessaire car il
faut toucher hoyaux il faut sentir sous
le doigt la fécule et bien la faire
absorber par l'alcool
et alors là vous lever pour la verser en
remuant comme ceux ci la zone non parce
que j'en ai mis tout est en réalité ça
ne sera pas trop
voilà et bien rouler les bus comme anti
faut opérer c'est d'une simplicité
vraiment enfantine et à partir de
maintenant nous allons commencer à nous
occuper de ce canard qui est au four
merci
alors voyez de l'école alors ici bien
d'origine de ces récepteurs il paraît
peut être un conseil je m'excuse de le
répéter
et oui bien sûr qu'ils en auront
toujours le répéter alors je vais
enlever les nuages qui assombrissent et
il est très il est doré remarquer le
doré alors on enlève le fil vous allez
voir parce que nous pourrons comme ça
nous allons avoir le temps catherine de
la découpe et également ceux qui qui me
semble intéressant aussi
alors j'ai enlevé le fil il me reste
cinq minutes
voici donc le canard nous allons donc
pouvoir représenter la cuisson rapporte
intérêts c'est-à-dire la cuisson dans
laquelle nous allons fait cuire scanner
novolyon la question enfin ceux qui dans
la lèchefrite alors voici donc le canard
parce que je vais m'amuser à le découper
un tout petit peu pour vous faire voir
comment son père alors je m'en veux
voilà je m'avoue présenter le canard non
ce n'est pas tellement classique non
plus mais cette réduction
cette recette est une recette très
connue en afrique ont fait beaucoup de
canard au poivre pas exactement comme ça
mais on le fait en bourrant le canard de
poivre mais ils ont beaucoup de poivre
vert là bas pour eux c'est une grande
facilité pour leurs aînés
il n'a permis de cueillir dehors et pas
conséquent ce n'est pas grave ça n'est
que nous qui avons peu de fois j'ai
essayé de faire une recette en quelque
sorte en économisant ravie quand vous
économisez geste inhabituel bien entendu
voilà alors tout en découpant or si
jamais quelque chose échappait penser
qu'on peut retrouver la recette nantes
et lille 59 alors voyez vous pour
découper en canard comme ceux ci la
méthode habituelle vous la connaissez
c'est on va on néglige le coûteux
largement répandue le canard de façon à
l'avoir bien sous la main
si jamais il s'attardait dans cette
opération on autorise une sève n'a pas à
fondre l'image alors oui on coupe ici
que ceux-ci et puis on commence à couper
ici une rencontre on rencontre bien
entendu le voir regarder comme le canard
et rosé n'est ce pas trop et on coupe
des aiguilles est comme ceci très très
fils autant couper environ 12 de chaque
côté va les voir
non alors la recette consiste à désosser
rapidement le canard le désenchantement
fait des émissions en télévision
alors on le désire ce donc rapidement ou
lentement comme l'on veut une fois qu'il
est désossé on ajoute du poivre vert
entre la carcasse et la chair comme
c'est le cas ici n'est pas et puis on le
fait rôtir au four d'une façon
extrêmement vivement nous battent ils se
trouvaient
un peu tard j'ai construit entier avec
un peu de pâte mais ceci uniquement
c'est parce que j'ai trois ans je trouve
que c'est utile ça permet de ne pas de
ne pas tomber de ne pas retrouver tous
les grains de poivre à l'intérieur de la
carcasse alors qu'il ne faut pas qu'ils
soient à l'intérieur de la carcasse mais
bien au contraire
voyez vous alors on peut continuer comme
ceci et puis alors bon mais je ne peux
pas y aller non plus regarder
alors on met le pouvoir intérieur on
fait cuire au four ans et une sauce
avait des du poivre vert que l'on cuit
dans le vinaigre que l'on réduit dans le
vinaigre quand ce poivre vert et bien
réduit on met du sucre que l'on fait
fondre jusqu'à ce qu'ils soient sous
forme de caramel et à ce moment là on
ajoute les deux ensemble on est un tout
petit font que l'on a préparé avec les
abattis du canard un peu de tomate
concentrée du vin blanc du sel du poivre
et de l'eau et que l'on a fait cuire
pendant environ une heure le tout
ensemble lié avec une pincée de fécule à
laquelle on ajoute un tout petit peu
d'alcool blanc c'est à dire de kirsch en
l'occurrence de pire jour n'importe
quelle heure à col blanc d'ailleurs
alcool de framboise ou de quetsches
n'est ce pas ce n'est pas très grave
c'est à son goût ses longs doigts soi
même je vais choisir le goût que l'on
préfère
et puis fort de cela on fait cette sauce
et avec cette sauce naturellement on la
passe et on sert le canard on a fait
cuire des concombres côlon avec lui tout
simplement au beurre voilà je suis un
cyclone a fait cuire aubert et que l'on
a servi au tour va l'envoyer ou
maintenant que c'est ainsi préparé
versez le reste de la sof sur le canard
comme ceci est bien voudrait dire bon
appétit au revoir et à donc à tous merci
raymond de cet excellent plein qui est
fort sympathique
[Musique]